surname first name age qualifications
you complete these data regularly on the
internet but do you know that once you
enter them you lose control of them it's
impossible to delete them to recover
them or to stop them being sold to other
companies
the european parliament has at last
decided to resolve this problem by
protecting personal data on the internet
it wants to introduce more transparency
a right to be forgotten and also to set
boundaries on data transfers to third
parties
the european rules that are enforced
date backed in 1995 prehistoric times in
the digital world
if any company
doesn't matter if it's from the european
union or from somebody somewhere else
for example from the united states
doesn't respect the european data
protection rules then the data
protection authorities in europe
everywhere in every member state can
find the company with a sanction which
is up to five percent of a yearly
turnout of that company in addition to
companies restrictions meps also want to
limit data collection by national
authorities to within the framework of
criminal investigations but
the rules will be applicable throughout
the world as far as european citizens
are concerned regardless of whether the
data are stored outside the eu but the
united kingdom the netherlands and
ireland have expressed serious
reservations about the european
parliament's position which they judged
to be too punitive for small companies